how do you feel man like I feel like
when we think of like Latin artists man
you're kind of
um on the Forefront of like you know
guys who
I feel like appeal to because with you
know when I was growing up it was like
MC Magic it was little Rob it was guys
like that who you know if you listen to
Little Rob he's you know if you're like
a A hip-hop head you probably might not
relate to his [__] because it was some
Chicano rap and there was like guys like
Capone and Mr Criminal and all that [__]
which was like really like specific
Chicano [__] you know what I'm saying I
feel like you're just making Dope music
and you happen to be a Mexican dude you
know what I'm saying like but you are
kind of like the face of you know for
sure I feel like I made uh everybody
wanna rap and and get in they baggie for
me so
I mean I'm proud to be the damn near the
face of it like I don't know who else it
is yeah no it's I mean nationally I'm
like bro you got records that and you've
done records with just everybody yeah
like the baby the baby record was so
hard yeah so far yeah it's definitely um
not yet I'm doing music with like all my
[__] everyone I listen to like idols
and [__] yeah exactly who was like the
one artist that you've worked with so
far that was like the biggest bucket
list like
artist the song the song was whatever
not his versus fire but we just like I
don't know why we even picked that song
we have future on the song on the
[__] Shoreline album
and you it just didn't I feel like my
verse is like it was like a throwaway
song why the [__] how do you how do you
let it throw away song that's what I'm
saying I don't remember so the future
was on the record but it wasn't a record
like when you recorded the song you
didn't know future was gonna end up no
no exactly I'd have been like nah guys
we got a code we got to go back in here
but you know what happened was that uh
that album was coming out when the group
was breaking up so it was kind of like
that I was just let's just get through
the contract yeah that [__] was like
[__] that up well I don't know who the
[__] put it together but
um how's everything I mean what kind of
bag would it take to get you guys to
come back together to do like a one-off
bag a super bag it's got it because I
already make a bag
look at your jewelry I'm like I just
want to go get some New Jersey too but
yo I feel like maybe in like five years
if you guys did like a reunion tour it'd
be kind of like it'd be kind of crazy
I'm not opposed to it we just need that
baggie for me because it's not not like
anything ever happened to where you guys
are like yeah no that's something it'd
have to be a good business movie yeah
exactly exactly I respect that what
about to do an album uh well yeah same
[__] let's just get a bag man right in
that bag would your bag have to be
bigger than everybody else's uh
it would make sense for so was that kind
of like a big reason like why what was
the nah because uh me and Phoenix was uh
it was everything was split 50 50. so
okay and then the the other homies was
only on like two three songs so right it
was really like you in Phoenix right
yeah I always wonder like when I think
it was just like it was just everybody
wanted to do their own [__] for real
because like Wu-Tang Clan I always
wondered like if you God gets the same
bag as Method Man you know I don't
expect you to really understand that
reference
yeah okay he's the one that was in
charge right there no that's Rizza oh my
bad
hey edit edit that out before they get
on my head bro you're
how old are you uh I'm about to be 30.
oh [__] bro I did not know you're about
to you're a grown ass man I don't get
old man what's [__] what's fatherhood
like for you man [__] I feel like I'm
getting older noted especially watching
him grow up how old is your kid now he
just turned four damn yeah he's big as
[__] he's like the size of like a seven
year old he wears seven-year-old Club
yeah it's like a real ass dude right
there running around your head oh God
about to start kindergarten you got to
be preschool uh no you know the
preschool but he about to start
kindergarten I think he's about to start
preschool okay let me ask you this
because I always we always hear about
terrible twos but I always tell
everybody that three is the worst thing
no yeah he well not nah I feel like he
was cool I feel like right now at four
he's crazy he's trying to like demanding
[__] he's like yesterday I took him to
the Natural History Museum because he
kept asking to go here like I want to
see fossils and butterflies we walked
outside to see butterflies because the
exhibit was on the outside he thought he
was leaving the [__] so he was just in a
butterfly to him at the whole time his
arms crossed and he's like I want to go
back inside I'm like bro we in the
butterfly thing he just wasn't even
looking at them he's like I don't want
to leave yeah I'm not ready
he's like the Menace he's like I want
toys I want this toy he wakes up watches
YouTube he's like I want that toy that
toy what YouTube channel is he into uh
just like a bunch of um what's that [__]
called like educational stuff man the
YouTube [__] is crazy sometimes my kids
be watching [__] on YouTube it'd be the
cringiest [__] man yeah he'd be he'd be
watching stuff and that should be having
like 200 million views yeah million
views I'm like this [__] crazy there's
like this dude who plays video games
with this kid and he's the most annoying
[__] dude ever
but I guess it works because he like
he's marketing it towards four-year-olds
so yeah shout out to your son man now
there's a bunch of random message he'd
be watching 100 like uh [__] watching
playground reviews and stuff like that
toy reviews playground
like I just feel like he my kid be
watching other kids play Minecraft I'm
like bro what the [__]
um so you got tag on the album you got
uh that was on the Chrome Heart song
right yes sir Crow hoarded uh you got
Kalyn shout out to Kailyn wrong boy